how did we get here what are you seeing
behind those closed doors that we don't
see
there's a reason why physicians commit
suicide it's just not what we're trying
to talk about what needs to be fixed
give the antibiotic give the percocet
give the xanax what chance that our kids
have that's what primary care is in the
united states mission impossible so why
is this message not out there
there's money why do we prescribe more
oxycodone in this country than any other
country in the world i'm an addictive
personality so it's either all in
or nothing so i love my patients but i
can't do everything that's just pure
crack cocaine for kids it's cost
effective and there's fewer side effects
and it's cheap
and it's available to everyone if people
don't know they should know
beautiful day
good morning guys here with anthony cave
he's an anesthesiologist here in the san
francisco bay
area and you're also a integrative
medicine specialist
integrative medicine medical specialist
so today guys we're going to talk about
the medical world and there i've seemed
to find there's a big gap
between us citizens and what's going on
behind the closed doors in hospitals
so we're going to talk about let's say
some of the disconnect
some of the challenges some of the
things that aren't going so well
at the moment i can't think of anything
brave anthony's here with us to do so
but it's not all doom and gloom we're
going to talk about
some of the ways all of us you me
anthony it seems i haven't figured out
so far but how we can implement things
in our lives
to make them much better during these
coveted times and just
life in general so anthony what's the
biggest
problem you're seeing right now that's a
wide question
but uh what what are you seeing behind
those closed doors that we don't see
and as an anesthesiologist you're seeing
people on the line of life and death
right every day every day we see
people right on the line and yet our
society has been looking a lot
like a pennywise pound foolish kind of
story okay
what do you mean by that so imagine
trying to save
a couple pennies here and there but then
in the long run losing
pounds and pounds and pounds or we look
at
for example masks right now right we
recognize there's a very
real benefit to masks in the correct
situation and we recognize that the risk
of transmission
situations can be very low we focus on
the things that might save pennies
like masks in outdoor settings where the
risk for transmission is low
but we're unfortunately very mute about
the pound okay about what are the
underlying risk factors
that increase the risk for severe covet
infection
for example okay so why do you think
there's no attention on
these overall factors these you know
there's sort of some big themes here but
like overall
health and society is going to better
society right why is there a lack of
attention on that
a healthy society is good for you it's
good for me it's good for every single
person because
we're all invested in the health care
system if someone can't pay for it you
and i have to pay for it at the end of
the day
right and money's a finite resource
people forget if somebody
is using too much of it unfortunately
that might mean less for somebody else
what are you seeing
anthony when people are on that line you
know
between death life and death you're that
guy holding them there
which has got to have a lot of stress
and obviously responsibility
what are you seeing in the health of
society or what can we learn from that
i'll let you take that one how did we
get here
how did we get here how did we get here
something that people need to recognize
is that
in the operating room in the emergency
room in acute medical settings
we do a phenomenal job with western
medicine
okay we save lives when you get hit by a
car on the highway
if you're unfortunate to have a gunshot
wound do you have a bad accident
right will do the best job with our
cutting edge medical devices and all
those things undoubtedly
sure but this is the minority
of what costs us as society as a society
and what costs us as a medical care
system
the heartache essentially we see the
sick people out there and it's rarely
from these types of acute
conditions it's usually from the
consequences of
high blood pressure from poor nutrition
from obesity from diabetes
when people get their amputations from
their diabetes when they don't have
eyesight from their diabetes when their
kidneys fail
this is what constitutes a lot of what
we see
and when they end up on the or table
because they need their limb amputated
or they have
an aortic aneurysm because they've been
smoking their whole life
how did we get here what happened
for the years and decades we had to
intervene
to help prevent this from happening it
breaks my heart
hot dogs in schools aren't helping well
i mean maybe the doritos help sometimes
i don't know
but i don't know if i can say brand
names like that but
yeah the vending machines to the kids
the targeted advertising of unhealthy
habits to our children right does not
help
so what do what do you think you're in
you're in the medical world the reason
these things are not being talked about
at a
you know there's not a lot of volume on
this topic it's because
where's the money to be made it's not on
prevention
i'm gonna throw you under the bus a
little oh say whatever you want
obviously but it's not prevention
right yeah unfortunately an ounce of
prevention
is a pound of treatment
but we're disincentivized it's the plain
unfortunate truth and if people don't
know they should know
you're just son of a disincentivized as
as a medical worker
as a as a hospital but well
pharmaceutical company dude you're
typically famous
now you are awesome yay thank you for
the great work you're doing
thank you you're you're a very health
conscious individual
i can tell i am i am i'm jealous of you
i want to be doing what you're doing
do it grab a girl go grab a gopro
anything we do there's always a risk and
benefit anytime someone's having surgery
for example
yes you might take out the appendix and
they might be just fine they probably
will be fine
but they could also die in the operating
table from complications of anesthesia
they could die from affection right can
i tell you one of one of the
experiences i had in in the medical
world
before and i've been to the doctors very
very few times i've had very
few injuries luckily so i was on a
mountain i i was mountain biking
crashed the bike broke my finger got
splinted up
healed up fine a few weeks later i was
getting this tingling like this tingling
down my arm when i was sleeping and so i
went
to the doctor and i said doc i'm getting
some of this tingling is there anything
i can do
and he and he did this do you mind go
for it
he's like see peter what we can do is
what we'll do is we'll just take out
this top rib here so we remove this it
will it will free i forget how he said
it but like the nerves will become
unpinched
blah blah blah we just gotta we just
gotta remove that part yeah and i felt
like i was talking to an auto mechanic
about my suspension not working
and i said doc is there what about what
about yoga or acupuncture is there
anything else i could do i'd rather not
start
dismantling my body over some tingling
at night yeah
and he's like you're sure me no that
won't work
not gonna happen and i didn't follow his
advice
thank god two weeks i have all your ribs
in place i still have all my ribs
two weeks later it went away it went
away and i'm
i haven't felt it since we call this the
tincture
of time in medicine tincture of time
god it's got a saying oh of course
because this this is what you just said
if things are on a spectrum and the body
has an incredible potential to heal
itself
undoubtedly nobody makes money when the
body heals itself
we need to face it so he's making a sale
uh i don't want to be careful i wasn't
there i don't want to speak for the
surgeon i wasn't i don't know what your
symptoms were
but traditionally the truth is that
when we go to medical school in the
united states we are trained to deal
with acute situations
which we do very very well right right
we are not trained
for wellness we're not trained for
health optimization we are typically not
trained
for low risk interventions so who is
trained for that
and who is you know you know giving us
that information in society
it's not the cdc right we're not having
our big organizations telling us how to
live i mean i'm sure there's stuff on
their websites but
i don't feel like there's some
especially this year you think there
would be like
okay the best thing you can do for
yourself
is getting a really good health i've
failed on that a little bit this year
i've doubled down on my chocolate intake
a double down go for the
i'm not a purist like you it's not
there's not as much dopamine in it
because
because let's face it shift food gives
you a rush
right but did you know that you can
retrain your body did you know that
the dopamine rush can be trained
no no we don't talk about it over here
let's check this
out the pallet the pallet adjusts
the pallet adjusts i don't know
that's that's a big that's a big sale
anthony how does my palette adjust
because because sugar is the dopamine
it's the quick hit
it is but there's more than just sugar
that can do it but see that once again
there's no what incentive
does anyone have to try to explain to
you how your
lifestyle can fundamentally change your
physiology
it's just not what we're trying to talk
about because and it's
and it's not the fault of doctors we
have 15 minutes maybe with a patient
maybe 20 30 minutes for a first time
encounter you guys are pressured hard
these days
right we are pressured hard it's not a
sob story it's the reality right right
we have very limited timing because you
do you want to be late for your
appointment
yeah no i mean sorry you don't want the
doctor to be late to see you right
right right well then if you can't take
extra time with your doctor
and have the next patient be late right
i mean it wouldn't be fair
so we need to be on a timetable yep to
keep everyone happy
it's really mission impossible that's
what primary care is in the united
states mission impossible
they ask way too much from primary care
docs
and there's no way they can deliver
who's going to sit down with you for an
hour to talk about
how your body can heal itself who is
going to sit down and do that
right who we're not trained we don't
make money because we don't get
compensated as much for preventive
things as we do for acute fixes
okay and i'm not going to comment on the
right or wrong insofar as to say
that you can tell me if you would rather
have somebody spend an hour talking with
you about your lifestyle right and how
you can prevent it
versus being on the or table 20 years
later because
your coronary arteries are filled with
junk from the lifestyle that led up to
that
okay what percentage of your patients
are there because of bad choices in life
recognizing that we don't have the
absolute truth number yeah it's probably
going to be well over
50 probably in the 75 percent okay okay
but it depends on many factors and i got
to say this to be complete here
they're gonna be some cancer centers
that look at only specialty care and
pediatrics
the child with the glioblastoma and the
brain it's very difficult to say
yeah yeah sure the child who's got a
tumor in their eyeball it's difficult to
say that it was a lifestyle choice
yeah versus the
older woman with uterine cancer with
risk factors that we know
revolve from elevated bmi and obesity
gotcha
so what do you want people to know you
you reached out you said
there's sort of an information gap these
days in your industry i hate to call it
an industry but that's what it's called
right well it's an industry
okay there's an information gap between
the public
and your industry i mean in a nutshell
these are all like five hour long
conversations we could have every one of
these topics
but what is what needs to be fixed
in this sense like what would be some
some remedy
quick fixes i hate to say that i don't
want to say band-aids we need deep dives
right
we need to die structural deep dives but
it starts
yes at the organizational level in terms
of community structure
and public health of course this is
going to be the bedrock
it's unequivocal how important this is
but right there is also
personal responsibility and agency and
this is the beauty the elegance of the
human body
it can heal itself with the right
empowerment
and to answer your question of what is
the single most important thing is
patient empowerment
everybody can heal themselves to an
extent
but their environment may not enable
them to do so
which is why it's a two pronged approach
of course the community and the
environment has to be optimized but we
can never forget
that the patient themselves has
incredible potential
to heal their body how is that
how is that approached now it's
approached that the patient doesn't have
incredible
control over their destiny or what do
you think on that no absolutely you're
correct because
the message is that you you see
commercials for
antidepressant medications for erectile
dysfunction medications instead of
addressing
the underlying cause what we forget is
that all these drugs that
are pushed out there have side effects
this is why what i said earlier in
western medical approaches we
unfortunately
forget the risk benefit of every
recommendation we make
okay everything as benign as any
medication may have potential
tremendous potential for benefit but
also has potential
for problems right and
this is the opposite of patient
empowerment where we look at lifestyle
where
you nearly unanimously have
tremendous potential for benefit without
the side effects
and with less cost when we look at 20 of
gdp going to health care costs
the lifestyle modification components
don't contribute to the 20 percent
number that we're talking about right
oh let's go up here here we are in
golden gate park guys such a beautiful
park in san francisco
okay so there's a lot we can do on an
individual level but it's hard
i'm not in my optimum shape right now
i've been in much better shape before
why do you stay in prison when the doors
are wide open
we know a lot of
uh i don't know how no it's good how how
how do you do it you it's nice it sounds
good anthony like i am empowered
but i'm also empowered right now i have
a craving to go get that
you know that cookie after this talk
right so
you're empowered yes okay but give me a
little more on that
like you're a strong you're a
strong-willed guy yeah and you're seeing
it i guess you have an advantage too
you're seeing every day at work the
fallout
from bad habits we all are but yeah yeah
no you more so
yeah but people anybody who's sending a
check to the irs
who knows that their tax yeah but
there's a disconnect there's a
disconnect like you're not connected
you're not upset
you're in those hospitals you're seeing
people dealing with type 2
diabetes which you just scared me about
because that comes from eating too much
sugar right
multifactorial but yes lifestyle and
refined
sugars yeah are one of the strong
contributors we believe to developing
and
particularly in children and when
children develop type 2 diabetes
it's the worst case scenario for us all
yeah because
they have a little life ahead of them
they're on the system their whole life
in the health care system and their
whole and not to mention their own
personal life lies it breaks
my heart i was telling you the other day
i had a patient in the operating room
uh-huh 12 years old let's go down here i
weighed over 200 pounds
12 12 years old 200 pounds over 200
pounds
and uh so what's his what's his chances
in life well there's
there's unfortunately a trajectory that
is not fixed
but is likely it's all about
probabilities
okay and unfortunately when that happens
that that patient still has the
potential to turn things around the
human body can
recover but it takes all the more
willpower and acceptance of
responsibility
okay so is it fair to say
that elements of the system
look at that as a perfect patient
because there's a lot of money
that's going to be spent on his life
throughout his life if he doesn't change
you know it's funny you say it that way
because it's
in some ways money to be
gained from the treatment that comes
from
long-term insulin from
antidiabetic medications that one may
take but it's also
moral injury to the healthcare system
because we're human beings
as doctors it breaks our heart it hurts
we don't want to see that child sick we
don't want to see their parents
sick right but what tools do we have
when we're constrained in a system
where we have 15 minutes with the child
and their parent
to talk about the lifestyle
modifications you ask what do we do
well it starts with education
empowerment starts with education and
awareness
but it's difficult to give these tools
to patients when the
cards are stacked against them the cards
are stacked against us all
in this type of me okay one way to
unpack i would say
okay easy food choice is fast food
that's an easy example that's cards are
stacked against you right
and i was just in southern california so
commercial real estate right we all
think
in california commercial real estate or
maybe across the nation is in the gutter
like downtown san francisco for lease
signs everywhere right yeah commercial
properties
but i was talking to a commercial agent
down there i'm like
how's how's the industry thinking the
answer was going to be terrible he said
oh my my work is great right now i'm
like whoa how how's that he's like
fast food restaurants opening up left
and right
because of the pandemic i guess right
because it's easy to go in and get
takeout
and yet and yet while masks have a role
the role is pennies
compared to the pounds of
that type of lifestyle nudging people
right right
so okay how about this anthony what what
the irony
everyone has a mask on here outside
as we're talking about pennies and
pounds with masks
what yeah what's your take on that
everyone has a choice to do what they
want
okay i will respect their choice it is
on
consider it is inconsistent however
to place so much importance on a 0.01
risk yeah versus a 1
risk and the 1 or 10 risks come from
an accumulated lifetime burden of
fast food and unhealthy lifestyle
choices that
far overshadows the 0.01 percent
risk recognizing those are somewhat
arbitrary numbers but orders of
magnitude difference
yep versus what we saw and comparing
what we saw earlier to
what most people are subjecting their
bodies to on a daily basis
um wearing a mask can be super it is
very important
give us give us the lowdown on that
please
i have my theories here's how i operate
outside
if i'm not close to people there's
ventilation uv light from all the
doctors i've talked to
outside that risk is so low they told me
don't wear a mask
around people up close and personal
inside definitely
i wear a mask are you at liberty to say
this or is that too
too controversial that's a very
reasonable approach i carry a mask with
me because i might run into yeah and i
have one with
both of the masks on hand yes when we're
looking at the 0.01
risk my personal risk profile is that
i try to optimize everything but even i
i don't believe that 0.01 or you know
roughly with this
if you want to calculate it however you
want an outdoor setting is
is very low
it is very low it is it is low it's
undeniably low
yeah and there is realistically more
things that are going to kill us
than being in an outdoor setting not
wearing a mask
recognizing that we have a mask with us
should the environment change because
hey
we might go into a cafe right now and
that's a different risk
so what this leads to also is what
you're saying earlier is fear
right and so we're not if we're in this
constant state of like
on the heels instead of on the toes
worried worried
feeling in fear mode in panic mode
that also hurts overall well-being and
health right
it's wristband it's hard it's hard to
measure that though it's really well
yes and no yes or no because like i was
saying earlier everything is a risk
benefit every decision we make in life
has a risk and a benefit
the risks of fear and a continual
state of concern and worry yeah is
actually not that difficult to quantify
we have heart rate variability
measurements
measurements there's so many ways of
quantifying the burden
of persistence unmitigated stress
elevated cortisol levels etc
that have very negative impacts okay and
living in a state of
fear particularly in childhood
can result in long-term
psychological and physical physiological
problems
and i've seen it in many ways like being
in the hoods you know there's this
there's this uh people are worried about
safety
and they're always on edge you know when
i was in i did this video in miami in
the hoods of miami right
the guys i was really cool guys but when
they got in there because we were in
miami beach they were chill when we got
in there
it's like their guard ramped up if
you're too relaxed it's actually a
danger for survival
meaning you're an easier target so you
have to have that fear mode up
to exist which has to be unhealthy right
it's unequivocal
this is not controversial yeah that
living in a constant state of fear
not only hurts your psychological
well-being but very much your
physiological well-being
undoubtedly there's no question so why
is this message not out there
on on a like a on a macro level at least
in the us right now i don't
i don't see it i don't hear it like
why is there not an overall well-being
approach you think there would be
because like we said an ounce of
prevention
is a pound of treatment right yet we
don't have that type
of incentivized public health structure
looking at the macro scale we don't
incentivize these things
and in your training in med school so
that the public health system doesn't do
it as well as it could
it does a good job in many ways and
we're not downplaying it right there's a
good job but there's much more
there's always room for improvement
bashing always room for improvement sure
at the individual doctor level
it's partly not our responsibility the
same way as it is a public health
message because we deal like i said we
deal with acute people we are trained to
save lives
when someone collapses right here we
know how to do cpr defibrillate then we
save lives
right in the moment very well when we go
past that
we drop off very quickly in our
cost-effectiveness
of prevention and treatment we can do it
but not cost-effectively
because we have 15 minutes at a time
what are you going to do a patient lives
there
99 of their life at home at their school
their work whatever what is 15 minutes
in the office realistically going to do
other than
manage some medications try to talk
about smoking cessation trying to talk
about lifestyle
and then go to the next patient because
we don't want to get a bad yelp review
if we're late to see patients that's
right
we're under so much scrutiny what are we
gonna do is it getting harder
in your industry suddenly it's getting
harder it's getting harder for doctors
what in the last five years
ten years it's been longer but well
you're young you haven't been in it for
40 years
we unfortunately have social media that
is escalating and it's very difficult
when we're trying to do what is right
from our training from the decades we
spend in school
running licensed yeah and then having
people
with perhaps less training and less
education
in our field trying to review us is
a difficult situation to put us in who's
trying to review you patience
okay okay it's a little bit it's a
little bit challenging
to try medicine is a little bit
different than a random industry because
the customer's always right is a typical
business the patient might come
and the common example they want
antibiotics they want opioids for pain
they want i want my trim at all doc i
need my
percocet criminal what's that trim it
all what's that um it's a synthetic
opiate it's kind of like um
it's a weak type of opioid if you will
okay so people who want to and this is
very real and this is these are the
struggles that we have
because we cannot give out opioids
liberally we have we're no feeling
epidemic because
pain was viewed as the fifth vital sign
uh many people will say
because of industry influence to help
doctors be more and
concerned and more um receptive to
prescribing opioids
for patients in pain and at a fear of
being negatively reviewed
and it's easy to if you're put if you
have to keep a volume of clients and you
have to be on time
the easy out would be here's the med
give the antibiotic give the percocet
give the xanax and that's that that's
band-aid stuff right this is all this is
nearly always banded there are always
exceptions but by and large we're
talking about band-aid solutions
they're gonna you know as an example
they're gonna be patients with cancer
terminal
yeah who yeah they might need percocet
they might in their last five years of
life the last six months left yeah they
might need
okay oxycodone but these are that
stuff's terrible i took that oh
it is like i had like a like a crazy
dreams and it was it was like a it was
like on psychedelics or something but
not in a good way
and yet why do we prescribe more
oxycodone in this country than any other
country in the world
this is this is getting really
depressing so anthony bring
bring this ship around give us give us
the hollywood ending no not the
hollywood ending but give us give us
something to go for or hope for let's go
up here this is a cool little
trail system look at how fit people are
here though you got to say
this is the way to go this is the way to
go it's a nice environment
people taking responsibility over their
own health yeah
in the context of them having the
ability to do so an area where the
weather is
amenable there is a park there are
sidewalks we're not worried about crime
we need to recognize we're in an
environment that facilitates this this
just the everything's
set here for it a lot of places don't
have this yeah and
and we never want to blame blame games
are not how we do things in medicine
but empowering is what we need to do
more of okay so this is this is the
solution this is where we're gonna get
out of this thing
this is one one of the solutions okay so
break it down for us anthony empowering
other than making good conscious sober
decisions
which i'm even ha i'm having a hard time
with myself
seriously with the sweets that's my one
thing i don't drink i don't do any drugs
you know sweets that's good for you
ready but see you've already you got to
focus on the right things
how did you cut those things out
the drinking ayahuasca okay i don't know
if that's a pro
i don't know if that's a positive thing
in your world but
it was a very powerful psychedelic that
brought me out of it
well then i think it's then it was worth
it there's a point there where you have
you've changed a lifelong habit yes
through one experience that that's a
very
uh it's hard to argue against that let's
put it that way yeah and i
and i never thought i never thought i
was an alcoholic
and until you stop completely
it was like there was always a
refrigerator humming in the background
like you know those old refrigerators
that always make that noise
you don't notice it most of the time but
it's always there and so every time i
was at the you know start of a vacation
or the end of a long day go to the beer
and it was nice and it was relaxing
and i'm not i'm not like looking down on
that or anyone that drinks it's not my
point but for me
removing it was like it opened like this
light this light came into my life
and by having a i'm an addictive
personality so it's either all in
or nothing a lot of questioning people
are like that
so by having nothing there's never a
choice it doesn't take up any mind space
i never have to think about it i don't
battle over it
that sort of thing so so you just
have provided part of the answer how
people
feel when they're healthy people have
from childhood oftentimes live the life
unhealthy
and they believe that's the status quo
when they get a taste
of what a healthy life is like it can be
life-changing the example that i like to
use with patients is that
imagine a tennis ball that's soaked wet
it can't tell if a drop of water comes
on because it's already saturated with
water
if you let the thing dry out they have a
dry tennis ball
yup and now a drop of water comes on it
then you can tell oh
there's something something's different
but people we live our lives in a state
of chronic stress
chronic unhealthy behaviors from diet
lifestyle
stress from our environments all the
other issues we talked about it's more
than just the patient it's the
environment they live in
but it's hard for them to see what as
you said the light
is like when you live your whole life in
this route even in your
victoria department yeah inflammatory
environment yes
yeah but one people realize what it's
like
some not all but some will never want to
go back
that was your experience yeah it was
personally my experience as well
so it's the realistic
the realistic approach or the cold hard
truth is nobody can do it for you
you have to want to do it yourself is
that is that fair to say
that's part of the solution because i
mean kids can be educated
obviously that is one thing and they
need good examples
but when you're an adult you need to
have the cards
not stacked against you as much as they
are now and our society
makes it difficult to be healthy
and to be responsible and to accept
responsibility
for your health why does it why does it
make it difficult there's money
you need to follow the money when it
comes to our health decisions we think
we're in control of our health and we
can be in control
but that's not the message that we are
given when we are bombarded
from every angle by advertisements
trying to peddle
right unhealthy behaviors when people
make a buck off of our health
it's hard when people know what makes
our dopamine rush
it's hard for us to resist that
and when we target our kids for this
what chance that our
kids have it's mission impossible like
like i just remember growing up with a
cartoon i mean uh commercials for
captain crunch oh and tricks
cereals right yeah i mean that's just
pure crack cocaine for kids
there is nutrition it is almost like
smoking some
will consider it to be like smoking
where there is no
benefit right and only harm okay because
the nutritional
value of all those things you're talking
about is nearly zero
and the harm is incredible and it's
marketed
in a fun jovial positive way it's all
manipulative it's all manipulative
and but we're manipulating the health of
our kids
this is the health of the future what
chance do we have
and we're surprised that our health care
expenditures are approaching 20
of gdp that number we can't understate
that number when we're talking about
stimulus checks and all these things
going on 1.9 trillion is a huge number
yet we spend so much
unfortunately on feudal medical care
every year
okay i was going to say there where's
the where's the good way out of this
but the whole system needs to change in
some way shape or form
well you're saying the the emergency
care or the like the very
you know what's deemed as western style
of treatment is is nailed down pretty
rock solid here if i need brain surgery
this is the best place to be right yeah
fair to say very
preventative not at all no no
and so how does that how does that turn
around it starts
by educating and raising awareness
and by recognizing what cards are
stacked against us when people
realize what they're being fed through
advertisements
and can start to look through the veil
that's trying to manipulate them
they get better insight into what their
tendencies are and how they're being
manipulated
okay to begin to counter those okay
would you say other doctors
share the same frustrations you know
that you're talking about today
we are a normal thing we're humans like
you we have hearts
we don't want to see people suffering
absolutely
but we're also suffering from
a really challenging situation where
the end of the day we only have so much
candle we can burn
before our wick goes out yeah and
there's a reason why
physicians commit suicide at the rates
they do it's a high rate
it is i know this physicians burn out
they have moral injury like anyone
else if not more because we are faced
with this
incredible burden that we can't do as
much as we want
about because like i said we're limited
to such short encounters
it takes a toll on us so you must be
pushed between the industry
that's basically the machine and then
the humanity
and when you're seeing that yeah
and then and so when we talk about once
a reporter once told me
they said doctor you can't die from
stress
right and i just i didn't even know how
to respond people die from stress
all the time and suicide is one of the
most overt signs of that but did you
know that you can go into heart failure
from physiologic stress
you heard of broken heart syndrome no
yeah it's a very very real phenomena
that
we have we doctors have seen all the
time i've seen it my wife is an er
doctor has seen it when people have
strong emotional feelings their heart
can go into failure and they can die
if you want an even better example
before surgery what we see
um classic classic example about how
strong
what our thoughts are and how they
control the rest of our body when people
see blood like when an iv goes in
yeah you know people can faint to the
side of sight of blood yeah
that is your brain reducing circulation
to your
to the brain itself causing you to pass
out your brain is controlling your heart
your blood vessels
causing you to pass out that is how
direct and how fast that relationship is
between what you're thinking and the
rest of your body
now these are examples of bad right
we're talking about people
fainting and losing consciousness and
having heart failure
but you can do the same thing as well
you can train your body
to be healthier as well to reduce the
inflammatory burden this is where
the non-western approaches are so
powerful this is where we have tai chi
and yoga and acupuncture
mindfulness-based stress production
right this is the good side there's a
way out of this there's absolutely a way
out of this
and the best part this is cool the best
part is
it's cost-effective and there's fewer
side effects and it's cheap
and it's available to everyone it's
available to everyone you don't need to
go to the pharmacy
to buy a chill pill you know who loses
out
and i'm not against capital i love
capitalism
and i love investing but the
shareholders lose out of that equation
if you don't count the patience of the
shareholders yes if you count the
patient as a shareholder peter
they win yes true who so this is the
question who
is the shareholder in your health and in
my health
and everyone in this park's health who
is a shareholder
okay well it's also other
people an industry that may not have the
same incentives that you and i have
yeah yeah yeah and we need to recognize
that at the end of the day we are the
advocates for our health
so we need to bring that power back it's
cheesy as that sounds right
we need to bring that back to ourselves
and i hate to say this it's life and
death
the end of the day when patients die
from a lifelong version of diabetes or
hypertension you know
that person lost their life and it might
sound cheesy but it's true it is a
life-and-death
situation where we need to advocate for
our own health we need to be in charge
because if we're not in charge who else
is going to do it your docs they love
you
you know i love my patients but i can't
do everything
i appreciate that truth
you can't i cannot export the
responsibility of my health to you
you have a wife that's in medical uh
give kids no yeah okay so you'll have
kids eventually i'm sure you'll have a
family
there's no way that you know dozens and
dozens of people i don't know how many
people you see
or your wife sees you can take care of
their
be responsible for their health it's
just not gonna happen so that that will
never happen
what is one way of distracting yourself
are you cutting the cord if you don't if
you're not bombarded by those messages
but isn't it like a whack-a-mole like
you it pops up somewhere else in life
you know what i mean a lot of times okay
we're gonna get in deep and this is a
whole nother conversation but i'll leave
it very short
a lot of times you're going to something
to cover up some other pain
it could be psychological pain it could
be physical pain right
so finding healthy alternatives to that
which doesn't sound too fun no this this
is a serious issue
adverse childhood experiences are one of
the
difficult to prove because it's
difficult to quantify but they appear to
be a very large contributor are you
familiar with adverse childhood
experiences well i can
i understand what you're saying like you
know traumatic experiences kids have in
their early years
and by traumatic we're talking about
things as major as
sexual trauma uh physical violence right
they could they could even be more
benign abandonment
uh abandonment yeah it is very extreme
correct absolutely
but even more benign things we're
looking at katrina i mean maybe that's
not benign but
you're displaced if we're looking at
maybe kovid not being in school
not being around kids being around
parents that are arguing because
they don't have the same income and they
need to economic burdens cause right
they lost their business and
absolutely comes home these things
affect the brain
and the developing child in ways that
are not benign
and this is well accepted in the
psychiatric literature is unequivocal
however benign they may sound to us as
adults for a child they're very
different and these
increase the risk of certainly
alcoholism
drug abuse but also heart disease lung
disease i mean the whole spectrum of
your health for the rest of your life is
colored
when you experience an adverse childhood
experience
and i gotta say i don't remember the
exact number right now but it's in the
order of at least 50 percent of the
united states population
of adults have experienced one childhood
adverse experience it's an
unbelievably high number okay so you
can't go back and change that
once you grow up but so but because you
said earlier but you were saying how
we have pains that we tried to cover up
yeah
yeah yeah this is not it's not just
oxycodone pain we're talking about pain
pain is not only physical pain yeah
psychological yes and pain
is in the brain 100 because you don't
need to
be pinched or to have a knife hit you
you
people experience pain without
necessarily
a noxious stimulus meaning pain is 100
in the brain it's real
but it is in the brain because you can
have a painful experience i can
some people can get pulled to the knife
and not feel pain yeah pain is in the
brain
so no matter what the stress the pain is
we try to cover it up because we're
humans and
there is a cost one of my teachers went
to medical school said the body
keeps count the body keeps going no
matter how old you were no matter what
you're trying to suppress
the body does not forget you can't out
age it
you know it's not like okay i'm 10 years
older now it will go away
it does not go away until you deal with
it and this is work
so it is empowering to recognize that
you can
change your relationship with that pain
yeah you may not be able to cure it when
patients have
terminal cancer they may not be able to
cure the pain yeah
but they can address it and when i have
patients around the time of surgery
if if they knew how powerful their
expectations in their brain were for
managing their post-operative pain
it would be a whole different ball game
pain is in the brain and you can change
your relationship with the pain and if
you just want one easy example yeah the
placebo effect
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know so many of
my colleagues write off they say oh it
was
quote just placebo okay just placebo i
ask you what does it mean to be just
placebo does that mean that you have a
treatment with no side effects
that is cheap because that sounds like a
really good deal to me
what more do you want you know when we
have the opposite we call the nocebo
effect
where instead of the placebo we think of
as
conferring a benefit the nocebo is
conferring a detriment
classic example classic example when
we're doing epidurals for women who are
laboring
okay we first numb the skin over the
back when we're gonna do the epidural
and so many of my colleagues used to say
ma'am you're gonna feel a little bee
sting
a little bee sting this is a tiny tiny
needle to just inject a little bit of
lidocaine to numb up the skin so when
the bigger needle goes in it's not as
painful okay okay sometimes the doctor
or the nurse would say oh you're going
to feel a bee sting
how do you think that preps the nervous
system right of the patient who is in
labor
i mean for goodness sakes place this
woman's delivering a baby they're
already in pain
they are legitimately concerned if not
freaked out many times they're going to
feel the feasting
peter i thought i had to be sting i
didn't like it all right yeah what if
you're allergic to bee sticks
what's gonna happen oh my god so this is
this is the power of our thoughts and
the messages we are fed what would you
say
oh i have so many tricks i i don't even
i tell them to cough
this is my when i'm placing i place ivs
every day for a living right okay i tell
i said
cough do you remember saying earlier
distraction what do the people do at the
moment yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you tell them to cough
you gotta concentrate on coughing
and patience almost nine out of ten if
not ten out of ten
the iv is in what what happened yeah
yeah i can i can attest to that
i'm a baby with needles it's just this
i'm at my weakest point when i see a
needle there
there you go if you can distract for a
hot second yeah but then we have
messaging like this and we're going a
little off topic but what does that mean
does
everyone was must wear a face covering
does that mean if you're far from people
if you're close to people oh you stay
six feet apart okay got that
and i know this business required it
maybe it might be a little bit
unclear because it's a bit unclear i
find it arbitrary because if we're out
in the if
we're out sitting in the field this side
exercise and all the other positive
things that go with it everyone must
wear a face covering
so if you're following the rules
and like my wife for example she's
always gotten the a pluses she always
did well like
this is hard for her my wife is the same
way right so you're so are you supposed
to you're throwing a baseball with a
friend
and nobody's around you do you need that
yeah and if you are not doing that are
you doing wrong
and this is a big problem i think we'll
finish it on this one
is the messaging is very difficult that
that being from
big corporations the advertising all the
social media stuff
we see then going to dockers learning a
little bit about your perspective of it
you know you have to push a certain
amount of patience through you cannot
look out for my best interest
spend hours of your day worrying about
that it's just impossible
it's insanity too to expect that right
you're not with a mask
it's okay we're we'll live where you had
your vaccines you had your vag
yeah yeah yeah what are the low risk
high yield benefits we can do every day
okay remove our health yeah i mean masks
are great in the right setting but
they're addressing like a zero point
zero one percent what are the one
percent what are they ten percent
i mean the fifty percent hitters that we
can control with our life
to not have to be on the or table one
day tonight
hopefully need chemo we don't wanna see
you you don't yeah if i didn't have to
see another patient ever again
i might lose my job but i am happy for
that if i wasn't an md
from stanford and harvard who practiced
acute care medicine no one would listen
to me
right but on both sides you have the big
title so people will
well and if that's what it takes to help
show people
as close as we can get to the truth
about what the truth that medicine is
how much we have in our own agency the
possibility of changing our health
outcomes around yeah in ways that aren't
pushed out to the mainstream
well then if that's one step closer to
the truth let's do that
love it you got me fired up oh i'm ready
like where's the where do i march where
do i like
what do i run on what flag do i hold we
haven't even you're scratching the
surface here this is fired up
yeah this is nothing this content guys
uh you know we're touching many things
i really think anthony needs to start a
podcast he does have a youtube
and facebook channel and a website
a couple so i'm gonna leave the links
down below
here let's walk let's walk this last bit
here uh
hope you got something out of that i
definitely did i feel healthier just by
being around
your orbit put yourself in the right
environment and the body will heal
itself
i'm fired up you change enough days you
change a year you change enough years
you change a life
who's right guys whose life is worth
changing more than your own yeah
in fact and by doing so you bring those
up around you and you're a good
inspiration
and role model we we all are role models
for everyone and that's why
we need to practice what we preach as a
doctor what would i be doing if i wasn't
living what i was saying
okay i'm gonna get fit starting today
guys i'm gonna do better and all
all of your viewers out there are gonna
take this and it's gonna imbibe in them
yeah right right
great thanks for watching anthony you're
awesome thank you all right until the
next one